assalamualaikum greetings apiece I got
to see something that really sat in my
heart it was a woman
one of our sisters in humanity who the
headlines were reading about how she
after her fight had her whole face
disfigured a disfigured face after a USC
match and I wanted to cover three three
points that I thought would be helpful
for some and some good words because
hopefully good words can awaken good
hearts point number one we often hear
the word of oppression and usually it's
linked somehow to Islam and Muslims and
the Muslim woman but is that really
oppression or is this oppression is a
woman who takes that gift that honour of
dignity self-respect that the Creator
has given her and she honors her body
her mind her intellect and she's not I
candy for out there for the whole world
to see she doesn't let industry doesn't
care for her use her and abuse her and
spit her out no she takes for her
example one of the best women that ever
walked the earth Mary the mother of
Jesus who wore hijab she is fulfilling
that legacy of morality of chastity
protecting her gift her beauty her
intellect is that oppression or is this
oppression how about a human being who
gates their face smashed like this you
know in Islam we have this concept that
your body has a right over you
you can't just in making a small example
you might go into an enterprise
rent-a-car you can't just do whatever
you want to that car it's been entrusted
to you and you got to bring it back
sound you got to bring it back they do
an expection at the end otherwise you're
gonna have to pay out of pocket for the
damage you've done but what about the
gift of life God Almighty gifted you
with this intellect and how how do you
think getting smashed in the face how
many brain cells are you damaging what
distinguishes us the human being from
the animal
is our intellect and now if we're
voluntarily destroying it and our beauty
and our facial features and this gift of
health we're out there destroying it is
that not oppression upon ourselves are
we not oppressing ourselves with the
person not be in a state of true
oppression upon himself or herself in
this case point number two is for what
what is it all about at the end fame
money attention likes what is it at the
end what do you gain if you lose
everything at the end and all these
things catch up to you they have a ton
of studies now scientific reports
especially in the case of concussions in
football and now with a lot of this
human cockfighting that it's sad that
many of our sisters in humanity and you
even have some of some women who are
going down this path but you have to ask
yourself for what at the end where again
Allah the creator of the heavens and the
earth has honored you why would you
dishonor yourself some of these things
don't catch up with you right away but
they do catch up with you what happens
when you continue to destroy your brain
cells you can continue to disfigure your
your face your body your health declines
and then after some time like most of
these fighters you end up being
forgotten but all those aches and pains
and beyond the brain damage starts to
catch up and what good are you what good
is the money that you've made and now
you got to spend all that money to try
to get that gift of health back and what
good was all those few minutes of
attention when all those people have
forgotten about you for what in the last
point who really cares about you who
really loves you is that these people
who now after you've gotten your face
disfigured they're making memes they're
making fun of you they didn't care about
you in the first place nor does this
industry this cutthroat industry who
uses you put you out there as a
commodity
as I candy half-naked selling your soul
selling yourself is this what god
almighty allah intended for you no he is
the one who loves you he is the most
merciful the compassionate the one who
honored you but then the human being
dishonours him or herself so that's why
God Almighty Allah sent messengers and
prophets he sent them with the same
message calling the human being out of
darkness into light to worship the
Creator not the creation to live by the
guidance that he has sent throughout
time you've heard of some of these
messengers Abraham Noah Jesus Moses and
the last the final messenger sent to
mankind Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon them all they all call
people to the purpose of life the true
purpose of life
and to live a dignified life worshiping
one and only one God and being morally
upright this is the message the
consistent message and now when you have
that blueprint and you know what you
need to be doing in this life the test
of life you'll end up not falling in
these trips and traps
that the Satanic force is set for human
beings and now when you don't have the
guidance you'll end up getting your face
smashed like this you end up destroying
your health oppressing your self so
hopefully some of these good words that
I've said with love and just seeing this
really sat in my heart
so hopefully for those who are thinking
to go down this field those who are in
it will reflect more and the more God
conscious we become the more we know the
Quran and the Sunnah the more we know
and live our purpose the more that will
be a guiding light for us to work to
please our Creator before we meet our
Creator and to honor this gift of life
that Allah the Creator that heavens on
earth has given us peace be with you
assalamualaikum